not many artists want their work to be
rubbish but that's what a Lynott's we
constructs his art from he sauces much
of his material like bottle tops and
cans for alcoholic drinks from recycling
stations in African countries you know
drinks helped to link the three
continents of Africa Europe and America
you know in the days that drinks were
brought first to Africa by Europeans and
and then they they took part in the
trans and Latin care trade entitled
triumphant scale the artist says this
exhibition in Doha reflects his body of
work on a large scale in both space and
time it's work that spans his rich five
decade-long career and that's Wiis
bottle cap series is at the heart of his
work made entirely from bottle tops it's
difficult to describe the sheer size of
this piece inspired by a 15th century
story about a king who imprisoned the
artists migrant ancestors who then
destroyed the city walls to escape he is
connecting are called bottles you know
tips and covers so by saying that this
is part of the colonization there is a
political message and there it's about
building bridges instead of building
walls and how also from Africa or from
the Middle East from different places in
the world artists produced work that
make sense to the entire world
and that's we says his work doesn't
begin with any political motives it's
only once he's put them together that
they're open to interpretation
Laura Berta Manley al Jazeera Doha